what happened to post-modernism that
great intellectual movement of the late
20th century that questioned all
objective conceptions of truth what
happened to it did it end most people
seem to agree that yeah it did end but
if you ask those same people when
post-modernism ended they can't really
give you an answer this may be due to
the fact that the idea of post-modernism
is still pretty foggy it's hard to
define it except as a reaction to the
modernism it was created to refute the
simplest way I can describe it is like
this modernism was a movement at the
turn of the 20th century dedicated to
building coherent theories about all the
new information science philosophy and
psychology or giving to us and
post-modernism was the period directly
after that in which the authority of all
those theories was challenged as well as
the very notion of authority in the
first place post-modernism is a good
catch-all for all the various and
chaotic ways of thinking that
characterized the later part of the 20th
century but as we neared the millennium
and the need to react to or a few
modernism seem less and less relevant
post-modernism sort of fell apart and we
were left with well nothing indeed one
of the key characteristics of our time
is its inability to define itself with a
set of intellectual ideas why is this
why have categories like this broken
down why don't they seem to suit the
contemporary age is it because
everything's just too chaotic now or is
it because we have too much information
and too much access for any one movement
to congeal and rise to prominence yeah I
think that's probably true but it only
tells us so much if we dig a little bit
deeper we can see that what's really
changed is our relationship to history
as science fiction author Bruce Sterling
once said history is not a science
history is an effort and the humanities
what sterling means is that history
studying it or writing it or knowing it
has always been a game
of meanings we look back and based on
certain material facts and contemporary
writings try to tell a coherent story
about past cultures and their values the
meanings they ascribe to their time and
existence now modernism and
post-modernism had something in common
their access to history was enabled by
paper by books books with covers and
bindings but more importantly with
beginnings middles ends modernist and
postmodernist thinkers had to resort to
books they had no other choice they
learned the authoritative sources on a
given subject either to accept or refute
them and by responding to the tradition
they themselves became a part of it but
these are different times the book was
replaced it was replaced with the
network and the network doesn't respect
history or tradition let's say you want
to know something about I don't know the
philosophy of stoicism I bet the very
first thing you would do is open up a
search engine probably Google and let a
complex ever-changing algorithm based on
views recency filters phrasing and much
more prioritize a list of results within
that list are all kinds of different and
contradictory positions all the way from
top university professors to some guy on
his couch and in each article there is
usually a comment section with opinions
about those opinions and if you can find
the author's name you can go back to
google and type that in see if you can
somehow determine via their Wikipedia
page or a number of Twitter followers
what other people consider the level of
their authenticity to be or you can just
go to YouTube which I often do and see
if someone's made a video about stoicism
that's a little bit easier to digest in
the network culture everything is fluid
poorly organized but extremely
persuasive narratives accumulate alter
and change as quickly as Google's
algorithm does and we have access to all
of them instantaneously sterling and
fellow author William Gibson named this
unnameable transition period of culture
a temporality in which we have this
great on
whirring from historical knowledge just
makes for a lot of unease and our time
the maps we have the network the
internet and all its social function
can't seem to do its job it can't map a
strong master narrative on to the world
we see in front of us now maybe someday
it will sterling gives it ten years but
it won't look like any of the master
narratives from literary culture really
we have no idea what a master narrative
in networked culture could look like now
it's easy to see that such a disruptive
break from the past also means and
uncertainty about the future about what
progress looks like a lack of confidence
in the market in nation-states in groups
of nation states like the EU in the
belief that democracy can be exported
around the globe are all symptomatic of
this a temporal transition peer in the
world and in the arts what you get is
this collaging of past and future in the
present the repurposing of old
structures and obsessions with predicted
futures of the past that never came
about
I mean what's more out of time for
example then stuff like steampunk it's
tempting to see this new historical
situation as a problem but you can look
at it as an opportunity to why not take
up the whirling elements of the past and
the future and design the contemporary
moment that you want to see in art in
your personal life or in the public
space then maybe the highbrow philosophy
of the future can't be canonized maybe
there never will be another Charles
Dickens or George Orwell but there's a
great freedom in losing the Canon as
well as Stirling notes historians really
used to worry that their interpretations
of the past were clouded by their own
values maybe the good news is that for
us right now we just don't know what our
values really are so that whether we're
looking back or looking forward the a
temporal age and the a temporal person
can finally see
with clear eyes I want to thank
everybody so much who's pledged to the
channel on patreon you're really making
this possible you know I do this full
time now and I've had such a great time
focusing all my energy and effort on
making I hope really really great
content for you and there's a lot more
coming up so if you haven't already I
want to ask you please to pledge to the
nerdwriter on patreon as little as $1
per video everything helps I mean if a
bunch of people do $1.00 it adds up so
don't be afraid to do a little if you
only have a little thank you so much I'm
going to keep bringing stuff to you next
Wednesday and if you want to check out
my last understanding art which is a
poetry analysis click around here it's
about Lleida and the Swan by WB Yeats
one of my favorite poems ever and I love
that video so thank you so much again
and I'll see you next time